[Background Music]
Menon: WeVideo was prepared
For the purpose of providing the possibility of listing digital stories
Creating videos for everyone and anywhere.
It started on Android
Because we noticed there was no attractive application on this system
To create videos.
Add to that the great speed with which the basic Android systems were deployed
Which made us choose it at first.
Since then, most of our investments have gone
In the development of smart phones
To Android.
We've made a great distinction among other Android apps
As we provide you with access to all the capabilities of the device
Through our application.
You can capture different clips and crop these clips,
We've done this with the Android platform
Which allowed us to access OpenGL air,
So we were able to make a presentation and preview
In real time.
Since launching our new application,
We have made very impressive investments on mobile.
Earnings on Android have doubled every two months.
85% of our users work on Android.
When we introduced the multidimensional design,
We decided to rethink the design of the application,
And rethink the user experience
To raise it to a new level.
Tsarigurdsiv: Many of the concepts of design have been multidimensional
Our true resonance.
We were able to create a pleasant experience
Users.
As a result,
We've seen a 100% increase in user interaction.
Represents the ability to reply to reviews
Great feature.
Check every day for all reviews
We analyze the data that we receive.
More importantly, it is
When someone is exposed to a problem
We can provide direct assistance.
Feeling great to see someone
Gives you 1 star to review
Then turns to give you four or five stars.
We love testing on the Play Store.
For example, we recently conducted
An update to the screen shots
Using colors and text,
This has resulted in an increase in the conversion rate
Reached 50%.
It's important to provide your app in different languages
To succeed in penetrating the global market.
We have seen an increase in the installation ratio of up to 200% within regions
We benefited from our application
And subscriptions to the Play Store.
Recently, we reviewed the in-app purchase flow level.
We wanted to know if we could convert more
To buy our products at an additional cost.
We decided to change the background colors, font size
For all elements.
We were able to publish quickly
We started selling within a few days.
We noticed an increase in the conversion rate
Amounted to 60%.
Menon: The basic Android system was great
Through which we managed to provide a structured application.
Through the deployment of applications that are characterized by speed,
Play Store card experiments,
Comments we receive from users,
The ability to invest with Google Wallet,
We successfully managed to get an increase in
Install rate and profit rate.